hi kevin hi martin
i heard you work for a car sharing
service called green
mobility and the company is using
serverless
yeah uh our dell team is really
productive thanks to serverless
computing
oh maybe you could share some tips on
how to use serverless to get your
developers more productive i would be
happy to
so kevin green mobility is a car sharing
service
yes we've run a car sharing platform in
seven european cities
we have hundreds of the cars and people
use them
for thousands of trips every day and we
have about 100
employees with headquarters in
copenhagen and we are listed on the
nasdaq main market
oh cool i guess many people want to use
cars but not necessarily own cars these
days
yeah like more and more people want to
live in cities and they're interested in
sustainability and they also prefer
sharing things rather than owning them
ah right so what kind of data processing
does the company need
to make this car sharing happen we
process hundreds of thousands of events
every day
trips starts come moves a car
trip ins and we could have built this
infrastructure for handling these events
with virtual machines
but there would have been a lot of work
instead we went with serverless what
makes it
much easier oh cool i love
serverless uh where do you store these
events kevin
we saw them in firestore we also have a
cloud segal database for other data but
we got better
data writing performance at a lower cost
with firestore
and firestore is serverless which means
less operation work for us
yeah so we will have sql and no sql
databases
ah got it machine learning is hot right
now
are you doing that too we're working on
it
we like to predict what cars will be
needed so we can put cars in those
places ahead of time
our plan is to export the firestore
database to bigger every night
then we could run reports in bigquery
and run bigquery ml
to to do the machine learning on the
data
are there any other factors that made
you go with serverless
we also have uneven demand more people
are driving
during the day than at night so it would
be inefficient to scale all computing
and databases up and down
ourselves but cloud run and firestore
don't do it automatically
ah why did you pick cloud run
specifically kevin
we really like containers and cloud run
those host containers without having to
worry about the service
if a server is acting up google fix is a
problem and we don't have to
also we like the billing model we pay
for container time even if the container
is handling multiple quests at the same
time
you mentioned building uh how much are
you actually paying for cloud run
our cloud one bill has been growing so
i'm keeping an eye on
last month we handled six million
requests with cloud run and we paid two
thousand claims kronos and that's about
320 us dollars
not too bad um how do you deploy your
containers to cloud run
when a polarquest is merged into the
main branch in our source control a
trigger ultimately builds and deploys
the container to our staging environment
and that happens about 50 times a week
and when we're done testing that
particular
release we mainly run a script to deploy
that container to our production
environment and that also happens about
50 times per week
are you building the containers on one
of your machines or up in the cloud
how are we using cloud builds in google
cloud platform all right gear our build
was
recently getting slow and taken 15
minutes and but it was easy for us to
change that machine type in one line or
in our cloud builder yammer
which reduced the build time to five
minutes only
oh nice so when you do 50 deployments
per week
that's a lot how do you keep these
deployments straight
we're big fans of immutable deployments
when cloudrun deploys a container
you can tweak settings and environment
variables instead you do a new
deployment
so immutable deployments prevent drifts
in our production environment
ah that makes sense kevin i'd love to
hear more about that
maybe you could tell us more details in
the next episode sounds good
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for kevin or me
please add them in the comments also
this episode was a little different from
others in the serverless expedition
series please let us know if you found
it useful until next time
[Music]